you may know that the Daily Show host
Trevor Noah who has hosted the show for
I think the last seven years since Jon
Stewart stepped away and it went from
being sort of a cultural icon whether
you watched it or not whether you like
Jon Stewart or not whether you thought
it was good or not it was a it was a
sort of main stream
place where politics Was Heard and
talked about and it was thought as the
most sort of irreverent political comedy
on television uh basically Trevor Noah
takes over and the things become
completely irrelevant so they're finally
getting rid of him and it's fairly
obvious they would have gotten rid of
him years ago but because of the
identity politics game like clearly they
couldn't do that which is also why he
got the job in the first place because
there were plenty of other qualified
actually funny people that could have
got it anyway MRC TV did a little
compilation on this and a study on uh
how many guests he had on that were
political by nature and whether they
were left or right liberal or
conservative or much more here's a
little info for you during his seven
year tenure as host of comedy Central's
The Daily Show Trevor Noah brought a
reliably liberal bias to the program a
NewsBusters study has found MRC analysts
found that from when Noah began hosting
the show in September of 2015 through
his final show in December of 2022 Noah
had on 100 59 partisan guests including
109 Unique Individuals of these 159
guests 137 or
86.16 percent were Democrats or in some
way affiliated with the Democrat Party
now I want to be clear I mostly at this
point in my career have right-leaning
guests on obviously we try to get
Democrats on all the time I would love
to have AOC on I would love to have Joe
Biden on I'll have ilhan Omar and the
head of Hamas what's her name you know
all of them I'll do all that stuff they
don't generally want to talk but I'm not
hiding what my political bias are right
like Comedy Central is thought of as a I
suppose an a political network but
everything they gave you everything they
made feel normal was from a leftist
perspective no one's coming here like
I'm bamboozling you as to what I believe
I tell you what I believe every second
of every day anyway here's a little
compilation of Trevor Noah's left-wing
bias
does this ever get
cheering for you when you walk into
rooms there seems to be this feeling
where you walk around the country and
people go it's a little bit of like ah
but it's also like Yay gender change is
not a trend all right it's been around
for thousands of years but if it was why
does the church care about it so much
first of all transgender people can
reproduce and secondly again why do you
care right you don't even let your
people reproduce right nuns aren't
allowed to have sex right priests can't
get little boys pregnant that same
Supreme Court ruling that struck down
Roe v Wade it also opened the door to
Future rulings that could overturn other
rights right things like the right to
gay marriage uh interracial marriage and
contraception here's the amazing part
for South Africa to achieve that kind of
black white wealth Gap we had to
construct an entire apartheid state
denying blacks the right to vote or own
property but you you did it without even
trying
you know one of the things that I find
interesting about this guy actually
probably the only thing I find
interesting about this guy is that you
know I'm very aware when I've toured all
over the world especially when I was on
tour with Jordan Peterson if I was in
some someone else's country you might
say something about like the food or
this or that but I went out of my way
not to insult the country not even to
not insult the leaders I think maybe the
one little caveat on that was I did go
pretty hard after Trudeau when we were
in Canada but Canada and America I
almost consider one thing at this point
this guy he comes here moves to this
country to just rip our country apart
relentlessly and endlessly